remember that time my parents were
androids and working for red skull in
the CIA and alive
neither do I what's up part 10 this is
the next recording session so I went
back through part five six seven eight
nine and got a whole bunch of questions
and I'm going to try and run through
them as quickly as possible because
we're running out of video gaming now
also fun fact I'm going to by popular
request by like three people I'm going
to head on over here and give this a
shot
how about how about it okay I don't
remember it being too difficult but I I
still hear like horror stories about how
the Human Torch missions are a pain in
the ass so let's go give it a shot I
don't remember if I did all of them but
I did this one and I did okay with it
it wasn't too bad I also went ahead and
did a whole bunch of the city gold just
so we could you know cut the [ __ ] and
get straight into the mission that was
actually kind of fun just running around
like completion run sort of thing
there's not a lot of like actual use for
wall climbing in these games like it's
there because it needs to be split like
you don't actually do it a whole lot for
anything like helpful you know you don't
win a fight by walk rolling that's why I
like the the fact that Webber shadows
did wall :
okay so let's answer one quick question
um what do I think of spider-verse um
well here's a ears a an answer that's
going to piss people off
I think spider-verse Oh Frank I think
spider-verse uh kind of sounds like a
bunch of wow I did not catch myself like
I thought either good thing I'll need
help to uh take out one guy follow that
health pickup with complete garbage
thing I think spider-verse um just kind
of sounds like really dumb fanfiction
it's really cluttered it kind of ruins
all the stuff that I liked about
Moreland and it doesn't really help
advance the story it's just kind of like
a big dead end for a little while and
like nothing is really is gained from it
except it introduced spider-gwen
I guess and that's really all it did
thanks slappy ready for another round I
am here to win back the honor of my
family name what I was watching fist of
legend last night in fact let's do it I
was going easy on you last time just so
you know yeah yeah like yeah some like
it's a big love letter to spider-man but
um I think it could have been done
better
all right oh boy try you'll be talking
to torture me oh god I need to gain some
quick height there we go
I'm gonna catch up you just watch no
[ __ ] you're not going to beat me this
time fella
we're on even terms now you punk ass out
is it fair when he shoots fireballs I
can't cheat like that that's good that's
good that's good dialogue I'll give you
that
people battling you
oh wait people his name has speeding it
sees all sass I just know he has uh yeah
[ __ ] you I pulled it out of the yeah
yeah okay mister storm loser sweet yeah
I panicked a little near the beginning
but I that wasn't too bad
I bet the the hard one will be hard
which his wife called that um anyway
also are like another thing I didn't
like about Spider versus that Peter was
like such a nonentity in that plot and
it was like constantly trying to like a
witch spider-man is the one that I care
about sure there's a lot of other ones
in fact there's even the one from the
cartoon I hate was there and that hell
was a little dumb and then um I don't
know people also asked me what do I
think about spider Glen I just kind of
asked like what's the point
the spider went like what I gotta go
finally check it to Daily Bugle I don't
get it also spot a Glen pool is very
dumb and has no reason to exist
I require sample you know kind of makes
me wonder what venom was doing at night
out here before beetle came looking for
trouble cuz you just kind of like
hopping around on rooftops you know
what's weird about this fight I don't
think you can actually lose beetle in a
fight or this chase I mean I think he
actually stops and wait for you to catch
up because story-wise it wouldn't make
any sense for him to try and get away
from you so you have to like put in
conscious effort trying to get away cuz
he just he see he just stopped me was
trying to get me to catch up because he
needs venom so like why would he try to
escape
alright let's go your big dumb warehouse
this is like the supervillain equivalent
of hey do you want some candy coming to
my van except it's like hey do you want
some human essence come into my creepy
warehouse filled with bubble shield whoa
hey remember in the comic when this same
kind of encounter happens but uh instead
beetle sucks him into a vacuum tube in
the wrists of his suit that was dumb
because no venom doesn't have like a
person inside or a skeleton or something
he just turns into into liquid that's
easy
that's [ __ ] hydro man
yeah why have projectiles to you strum
is to my understanding that this fight
is hard apparently so we'll see how I do
I you know what playing a video game and
talking at the same time very difficult
people on earth I I swear I am really
good at this game when I'm not saying
anything okay I didn't know you could
just climb on that
okay between the two of us I think that
was embarrassing for both of us because
I threw a forklift at a post and you
shot a laser at a post and I don't think
anyone really accomplished anything
they're not moving so I can throw these
boxes at you okay now you're just being
a dick stop oh that was cool okay you
know what I take it back you're all
right you know I'm going to not stand in
the way of those you could you stop
oh boy no no no I hate this part big
dump
beeping laser things if you can hit him
early enough you can stop them from
really like doing it
so what talks about the slightest that
you can't there's no health pickups and
by that I mean people to eat so you kind
of have to like do it in one quick run
we're making good time I just too much
smoke I can't see where he's going
oh I dodged that sweet get back here you
he's up with the grenades buddy
I thought Kong Skull Island I think of
all the giant monster movies that have
come out in the past like four years the
one I like the most which is sad because
there's been two Godzilla movies and I
don't know they've been okay oh yeah I
can hit you now all right fine
no no no I think that move kind of like
really hope that you're busy in a combo
to like like he's hoping that you kind
of get yourself stuck in one spot so you
can do that really all right please just
like take a hike I wish I had another
forklift to throw at you get dick there
I go your ass ah yeah it's pretty
graphic
that's worthy of being like a desktop
background that was cool All Right see
you later slappy really dumb that it oh
yeah the more story mission Wow we can
uh boy this is gonna go a lot quicker
unless I like you know go take a hike to
go waste time which I don't know if I
want to do in fact I think actually is
the next mission the last mission holy
[ __ ] I think I'm getting like that close
uh yeah well and I'm only 12 minutes
into this part that sucks I was
expecting this to take longer but
apparently I did a lot better with that
fight than I was anticipating well boy I
better run through these questions click
then um what do I think of the two
universes I think even though I grew up
reading the ultimate one I think the
original Marvel Universe is vastly
better and I think spider-man is more
fun to read when there's more than one
book happening at a time and like
clearly it's like a sale tactic but at
the same time it allows for like fresher
ideas because it's a collaborative
process between more than one writers so
when there's like amazing spider-man
running by itself currently with only
one guy in charge which is Dan Slott if
he wants to make a really dumb decision
he doesn't have anybody really to go
like tell um no that'll [ __ ] up the
continuity of the book I'm writing over
here so please don't do that
but if you had like web of Spiderman
spectacular spider-man amazing
spider-man and spider-man unlimited all
running at the same time that allowed
for a lot of variety because there was
like different stories that each author
could tell and it kind of kept them from
making dumber decisions right up until
Clone Saga which for some reason they
all thought that was a great idea but I
like when there's more spider-man
writers than just one guy
cut-scene Peter Parker what happened Oh
ow ah who are you enough tranquilizer in
your system to take down a really large
horse don't fight it
I know who you are Peter Parker I can
get at you and anyone else you know Mary
Jane Watson hey Parker leave my family
alone get in the damn car no femshep and
you get in the damn car Oh tokens hang
on
ah well that's um that's embarrassing
it seems that my priorities are slightly
askew I think this is the only box fight
that has like additional enemies just
kind of hanging off at the side to make
it difficult you notice you don't have
to Web them up because it's when you did
let me go out of your web shooter left
my cutting and web shooters a crazy
Lynch card and do you think there'd be
more traffic on the bridge than this
okay you're blocking so I'm gonna take a
break cause you look like you're about
this stem ship me in the face you know I
think of all the voice actors in the
same she's the only one who believed her
character again after this and shattered
Dimensions which is weird because she
only had like three lines in that game
like silver sable was such a nonentity
she was just an excuse to have like
extra bad guys in the juggernaut mission
oh oh come on really
you see if ultimate spider-man wasn't
such a punkin can throw cards like you
know the original one this fight would
be over a lot quicker you need mopsa for
these guys
we need to contain this this small child
is beating the [ __ ] out of all of us
it's really embarrassing guys I think
that's something that's funny about
seeing like high school aged under
Parker bite people at a costume is that
you still very much like a little kid
you know like he's still like mid swing
of puberty you know it's gonna be like
difficult for me to do that if you kill
me
[Applause]
oh all right now I like this segment if
it shows that she's not like just a
complete villain we're still hard on a
ps3 controller but on a ps3 you want to
fight not to kill innocent people
completely you're creating with a hard
school
okay help please maybe yeah all right
thanks
Thanks yeah I appreciate that you know
if I would be original spider-man this
would be a non-issue I could slow that
car all right head on out
hey you know what's funny is that John
DiMaggio police is like it's a bender
and Jake the dog and Marcus Fenix and
stuff he's in this game it's just some
random civilian you pick up off the
bridge all right you're gonna feel like
that I can just leave you hanging there
no mutants are people too okay say it
you dudes are people too all right there
you go
we all learned a valuable lesson today
racism is wrong I love this cutscene
okay can we stop all the what is wrong
with you
and they're thinking about it boy he
changed fast I love the bit of dialogue
at the beginning of this little segment
here smile I'll shut up
crazy silver hottie threatened my family
I can let any here he'd be doing me a
favor but then I still guilty about that
too because clearly I don't have enough
things to feel guilty about so now Here
I am trying to save the crazy woman my
life for anymore stupid
it would be on network TV yeah I got the
missin hey you think the Baxter
buildings automated defenses would kill
that horrible parasite monster that just
ran across the roof but maybe johnny
forgot to hit the button to turn on the
security whoa diverting over here so I
like the extra layer to this fight or
this chase because you can actually like
you've played as venom you know exactly
like the extent of how his his mobility
works because you've played it and other
fight scenes and chasing so it's like
really fun to have to like fight against
something that you've been doing
yourself all the Suns
oh boy I hope I he's getting away
see how they get you is that the he can
jump such high distances that like he's
always way above you for the most of
this chase so you're having like swing
kind of low you know so you can keep up
with him but a lot of people's first
reaction would just be like stay right
on top of him but that's probably not
the best idea there you would what's up
I walk past a token earlier I hope
you're proud of yourself well no no no
no no no that was bad almost screwed it
up out I do I don't know how I did that
I didn't even hit I hit the button it
punch him I love the sound effects of
venom just stomping around to the fast
yeah it'd be cool if the damage you did
during the chase sequences carried over
to the place like you could like
practically beat the boss before even
getting those spot where you end up
beating em lady crazy lady whoa yeah
you've got a shitload of range in this
fight like you can hit pretty while
you're standing behind him and he can
throw cars this is actually the only
fight I think that you have with venom
where he is capable on time
Jack silver sable no actually the
explosions from the cars can affect her
so you have to try and stay out of the
center of the field so when he's
supposed to make you they don't land on
earth or just stay away from the center
of the the intersection in general but
his tentacles also hit her ow
oh yeah yeah take a chill pill buddy
all right here we go we're making
progress
your ass is not drastic just gonna car
sir if I guess
what's the main character just cause his
name yes
there's this really great video called
time to just cause where someone finds
how long it takes the car sir after
playing like Egypt he just any of Just
Cause 3 he stands perfectly still and
does nothing and then I come on stop to
enact and then by like the three-minute
mark ii car surfing and like 20 people
have died because the AI is so wacky in
that game that you have to you don't
have to do anything and the game just
like those nuts not tired buddy
okay I should probably stop talking this
bike over here please over here there
you go well what will Hubble
settle down a tentacle buddy whoa oh no
please
all right we're just about there
ah if he's gonna blow himself up there
you go take this she see the explosions
in the background like happening in slow
motion
are we done Eddie
ah thanks goodness I didn't know how
much longer I was going to stay all
right
I think that's a good stopping point uh
this load screen spoiled [ __ ] so I'll
see you next time I love you Mary Jane